the lack of females being played on
country radio continues to be a huge
problem and a Michigan radio station
while whoever controls their Twitter
just made a shocking admission at how
bad the situation is so this started
when a variety magazine writer tweeted
they was listening to a country radio
station in LA and they played two
females back-to-back and he joked that
there must be a penalty for that since
females rarely get played well someone
at 98th kcq radio station replied
through the station's twitter account
saying we cannot play two females
back-to-back not even Lady Antebellum or
a Little Big Town against another female
I applaud their courage yeah so we're
assuming they so we're assuming the
station managers won't allow that tweet
since it's been deleted and the person
who tweeted it is probably in a whole
lot of trouble right now probably fired
but before was deleted Kelsea Ballerini
tweeted this to all the ladies that bust
their asses to have half the
opportunities that men do I'm really
sorry that in 2020 have to use a
conversation of equal pay there are
still some companies that make their
stations play by these rules it's unfair
that's incredibly disappointing Kacey
Musgraves who won Album of the Year at
last year's Grammys but barely God and
he playing on country radio added smells
like white male BS and why long ago I
decided they cannot stop me and also
said and yet they can play 18 dudes who
sound exactly the same back-to-back
makes total sense
Ivete I told you about this a long time
ago yeah where I worked a radio for
years and even when I was in radio years
ago I remember working at a station
where they would never play to limit
back-to-back
I worked at a station where they would
you would never hear one more than one
female artist an hour oh really
let's like find it's just like if that's
actual main date like I can see maybe if
it's a male running the radio station he
just wants to you know play what he
wants the plane he doesn't really you
know break it down like that but the
actual fact is like your actual main
date is you can't play I'm two females I
will I will I will say this and it was I
don't know how it is now with that
station in Michigan but I will say this
and that is from years ago when those
were the rules this was less of somebody
who dislikes women
female artists making these decisions
all of these decisions were based from
my experience on an incredible amount of
research so this is companies that spend
a lot of money on research that gets
them to this point but they just don't
apply they're like you know like some of
the biggest artists that we talk about
is hutch me just like what people would
be that offended if you play like carry
on do it and Miranda Lambert back to
back and then Lady Antebellum like no I
don't think it's true I don't think it's
about being offended it's not because
it's not about being offended because I
don't think anybody would really truly
believe that it's about keeping somebody
for 10 seconds longer just so it's all
is all right that's all it is let's
bounce
like do you register that when you're
listening to the radio of the like oh
they just played two females back back
or whatever like two male people do yeah
no but no no like do you subconsciously
care do you consciously care and I don't
know the answer to that right but but it
is a it is a problem in and obviously
it's still a huge problem and of courses
I've never heard of this that's
ridiculous yeah Paul says I wonder how
many station directors are female I
don't think yeah I don't know what the
numbers are there's that Christmas's
this is dumb mix is what is it the 1950s
that's going on in country radio Matthew
says this is silly it shouldn't matter
who sings the music if it's created to
be played radio stations need to get
with the times this conversation with
country radio now in 2020 this was the
conversation that rock radio had decades
ago yeah that was you know it's it's the
exact same it's this the exact same
conversation Paulus is a question of pop
stations are the same you know it's like
no I don't think so because then I mean
route is like Feeny you nominate Pappas
you should do yourself no favors by not
playing Taylor Swift and Ariana Grande
as much you can yeah there's way more
pop females than there are pop males to
get out of the radio